please God uh if I care about this
[ __ ] podcast whatsoever just help me
get my [ __ ] job
hey hey so much
yes in G app 26 indeed YouTube fandom
fandom and M s ng fandom and M like
subscribe do your thing on the audios to
videos patreon fans jump back in become
a patron of the show help us continue to
do what it is we do brough thing is as
well these out of sometimes I feel like
I'm not translating properly yeah what
you mean when I say we want to do this
like I when I say we want to do this
full time yeah I don't think you've okay
I need your help
yeah man so patreon forward slash its in
gigs podcast that's funny there's tears
upon tears and there's one tear in there
for like five grand a month if you're
rich rich rich you're rich rich if you
dare put that on brav I'll come to your
yard I will do something de Comte Oh
hard upside come to you out of five
grand a month so yeah guys if you want
shout outs if you want to share your
opinions if you want to have live chats
with us those are all the options
available for you on the patreon so jump
on help us do this full-time help us
help you man help us help you man
because then we can get a studio we can
get more episodes out per we yeah we can
quit brother well that's how once you
quit my job
oh god when I say I once you quit my job
brother
so for you man that don't no more no one
knows I took a little hiatus from work
for a little bit and I've recently gone
back got in the [ __ ] office I went
back on last week Thursday yeah got in
the office I'm [ __ ] now there was
torture it was absolute torture I hate
you in there just everything I hate just
existing in there even when no one was
talking to me and I wasn't doing
anything just sitting there I was like
this is hell this is hell I hate I hate
it so much
it's very monotonous always extreme
in honest less ways well I assume anyway
I don't you know it's like hard to like
the older I get the more I realize like
it's really hard to try and instill so
when you're working for a company like
obviously the company has a values yeah
they've got values that they want to
instill upon their staff and their
customers and stuff like that
yeah and it's so hard for me to instill
those values yeah
when I really don't give a [ __ ] of
course I just it's hot I just I'm tired
of pretending from I just don't give a
[ __ ] yeah and it's just all these values
and it's just like I have to have a
meeting we have like my boss and they're
like oh can you give us an example when
you're and this is to get my bonus
fan-like can you give us an example when
you're expressing this value and doing
this and it's just like no I can't
I can't cuz I don't care I can't because
I had like a meeting I could exit me in
yeah and I said yeah were like all these
plans when you get back and all this and
all that and I'm like yeah yeah yeah and
then they were like oh so we need to
talk about development or where you want
to do and this and that and I was just
like right guys don't get angry or
whatever but can I just say something
and they were like what and I was like I
don't want to do any of that they were
like are there any different parts of
the business our company's massive loads
it impossible any business parts of the
business you want to try out I was like
no I don't do any of it just I don't
want to do one bit of it that's funny I
just want to come in
yeah do my [ __ ] yeah grit my teeth for
eight hours and go home and live my life
is that so hard
Debbie is that so hard is that so hard I
just want to come in do my [ __ ] and go
yeah like just let me do it please
but you can't say that I work on it's
all ya know that bit I said I didn't say
I want to go home I didn't say I wanna
come and get my teeth oh [ __ ] off oh
yeah I did say I don't want to do any of
us I said I just want to come in and do
the job I applied for yeah this is the
job I applied to do I just want to said
is it so wrong
want to come in and do this job yeah and
they're like no no no that's fine that's
fine we just need to put something on
your development plan as I [ __ ] my
development I don't want to develop here
if I'm developing here I'm losing in my
real life oh [ __ ]
that's volumes that's bro the further I
come here the worst my real life is just
I was it hot not focusing on the faces
yes bear in it yeah but yeah - I hate it
so much so please guys please for the
love of God please help us please it's
not gonna is literally like I think the
first tier is 1/3 pound a month free
banner month field that's literally
nothing you spend more you probably
spend more on I don't even know
everything you spend more and everything
than what you three pound a month three
pound a month you won't even feel that I
spend more on that on my way to work on
the first day of the month and I don't
know what I'm probably breakfast
probably yeah
so guys it's not if ten of you do it
that's that you could please help me
quit my job please God if I care about
this [ __ ] podcast whatsoever just
help me get my [ __ ] job
hey hey you so much [ __ ] hey so much
I sound desperate right I don't even
care hey a [ __ ] hater you can tell
bro this is funny cuz I don't know how
many episodes now I've just gone on and
on and on about how much I hate everyone
does everyone is that reminds me
actually shout-out to my main man Lewis
the other day so I've got a good friend
of mine called Lewis he's exactly like
me in that most people that he openly
just can't stand his job yeah he can't
stand it and he wants to do anything he
actually has decided as of late I'm not
gonna say it has anything to do with us
it'd be nice if it does have something
to do with us but he said he wants a
sigh his own podcast etc etc etc yeah
and I was super happy when he said he
wanted to do that and he's just talking
about I hate my job I hate my job I hate
my job I hate my job I hate my job I
want to quit and he's lazy saved up
like a fair amount of money and he hit
me up the other day and was I want to
quit yeah like I've got this much money
in my bank [ __ ] em I just quit and then
he was a too much of a risk and he's
just going back on himself back himself
and I just had a little word of him and
I was like whatever I just didn't hear
from him and then text me the next day
and was that bro I just quit
what into his office I opened his laptop
looked his he's plan for the day in his
calendar I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
whole damn yeah literally [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I'm out Todd his manager I'm done here
he said I'm done walked out the same day
that's provided bro it gave me chills
bravado
he gave me chills I can't wait for the
day I quit I can't wait I can't wait I
make I make a scene when I leave in the
evenings yeah every single day
especially if it's Friday yeah I make a
scene in the office so the way my office
works is that people have like like you
have like an early shift a mid shift and
lationship yeah but it's barely that so
it's like halfway to half for yeah like
a third of the office to do half a tower
for another third one 9:00 to 5:00 and
another third would half 5 and 1/2 mile
high five yeah
so if I'm when I'm leaving if there's
people still there after if I'm not on
the lake big man I stand up put my [ __ ]
on everyone's I are see later James and
I'm like you man enjoy your last hour of
hell you [ __ ] prick I'm going every
day every day they hate it and all the
time enjoy hell you [ __ ] [ __ ]
enjoy this cuz I'm gone really Wow
really they don't hate as much as I do
why is he saying it yeah cuz you're
talking I remember you're talking about
when your colleagues that wants to own a
bike store or work in a bike oh my now
will--the
my main man will Willard no even William
will add will add bro will needs to
bounce yeah cuz I've said I've deficit
before one here I think when I asked him
like what do you want dude do when he's
worked so he's worked at our office for
11 years
yeah and I said to him do you want to
retire here my look me in my face and
said hell no hell no he's in his forties
II said hell no
and as I breath slash your about your
board halfway there oh you're about to
flash and he was like now I want to
retire here and I thought what do you
want to do then he said yeah man I want
to work with bikes he loves mountain
bikes and rode bikes and all that [ __ ]
I want to work bikes man it's just like
bro it annoys me that just just the fact
that I know how he is as a person
yeah it frustrates me to death that to
know that he's not ever gonna do it yeah
I can rant in his ear right and is it
maybe if I it maybe maybe just maybe
because I've known him before we even
side this now maybe just maybe if the
day comes that I quit my job yeah then
he might be like rah rah I Eliza I can
make one but I emphasis on them maybe
maybe he will because I just know how I
just know how he uses another
I highly doubt I was gonna do it but I
would love if he did because he hates it
there he [ __ ] hates it there and you
can see how long has been there because
he gets emotionally invested in all the
pathetic office politics that go on oh
god [ __ ] that like when I was off they
had like a whole restructure and loads
of managers got made redundant and all
this stuff and then I'm coming back and
then everyone's like James James James
have you heard have you heard like have
you heard what's going on nor this and
all that have you heard this and then
like I heard obviously they told me the
full story and I'm like oh cool cool and
then I oh my god it's big drama so much
and I'm like really though drama who
gives up they're gonna be alright
yeah don't leave here and they gonna
have a job yeah like they're gonna be
fine yeah what do you mean drama your
jobs fine as long as my there's no as
long as my job be safe yeah there's no
drama as long as I'm not sacked
trust me this I'm trying I don't give a
[ __ ] about any of you didn't give a damn
and if I do give a [ __ ] about you I'll
see you after work
yeah that list fine yeah I there was no
drama for me but that's [ __ ] I was
chilling what's funny is that I'm
speaking of like my man that got will
where his name is obviously Louis and a
lot of people like bail on my flat me as
well a lot of people will have the fear
of taking
first step Oh 100 I feel like that's
everyone's everyone's daily battle or
daily struggle in life 100% fear because
that I'm I'm pretty sure everyone has an
ambition in life like whatever you're
currently well I won't say everyone but
a lot of people that are currently work
in their current jobs have an ambition
to do something else they're just doing
their job to get the funds to [ __ ] off
and do something else
yeah but the comfortability of your
current job will keep you there Oh 100
and the fear of taking the first step ie
quitting your job to do what you want to
do is the biggest risk but no risk no
reward
exactly so that's why exactly when Lewis
said there's too much risk about
quitting in quitting quitting once he
had done it yeah I said to my man like
bro you don't realize how important it
is even if you get a new job tomorrow
yeah you're destined for better things
now just the fact that you actually had
the balls yeah to walk into work and
just say [ __ ] this oh [ __ ] this I'm gone
yeah like [ __ ] this place and just walk
out yeah that takes so much fussing much
groans so now that you've done that yeah
you can do anything you can do anything
you want yeah you've done it now because
you've taken that first step the fear is
no longer there Oh bro and I feel like
do we have fear doing this no because we
weren't really sacrificing anything we
sacrifice in bar but it was the more of
the fear of the response bro I was yeah
I was terrified yeah I was terrified
I was I was I remember I was saving up
because obviously all the kit was
[ __ ] expensive yeah so I was saving
I'm saving up saving up and but the
month before we started yeah I had the
funds the month ago before okay I had
the funds okay and I convinced myself
that I didn't have the funds because
deep down I knew I was just too scared
today yeah cuz I knew once I've actually
bought this [ __ ] you have to do can't
just sit here and it was actually had it
yeah yeah now we actually have to do it
the fear of taking the first step is
wrong it's very very wrong yeah man now
it's easy breezy
I'm not I'm not advocating everyone go
out there and quit your job today or
tomorrow obviously not today but
tomorrow whatever but if you've got an
ambition in mind or Drive or something
else that you want to do just just stick
to your guns man because there's money
to be made in this world and there's
always room for someone it's not because
there are millions of people that do
podcasts not millions people are
successful but
stop one per another person from doing a
podcast you know I mean there are
millions of athletes anymore but that
doesn't mean I can't grow up or my kids
can grow up to be an athlete exactly
because LeBron James is one of the best
ball is I hate the term saturated market
yeah when you say that I want to be
something I want to be a footballer I
want to do this and people that it's
like nah fam don't tell people don't
tell people that because like like
perfect example F example for some
reason we were just bored yesterday and
I wanted to know what the average
lifetime of a podcast was yeah average
lifetime so like I said podcast
saturated market there's millions of
people that have podcast yeah but the
average lifetime is what did we say it
was just over five months just over five
months yeah and we are what five months
in coming up - coming up no it wasn't it
was hundred it was a hundred and fifty
something days and we're like we're like
a hundred and thirtysomething yeah so
we're just behind ya we're just behind
you so with that in mind say if you
everyone starts on the same level which
they don't but let's just say there's a
race for successful podcast let's just
say if you want a successful podcast
there's a race and you stop you start on
this base line here and then everyone
that's when everyone looks at that one
base line sees all the means a podcast
yeah and then says rye that's a
saturated market yeah sure that's what
you want to do yeah yeah as soon as you
make it past 150 something days the
majority of them are already done yeah
you're already in the upper echelon of
there's 150 something there so once
you've made it that part the rest is
easy
then everyone might look at it and be
like oh and that's how you gonna think
of it man but season yeah they know what
season like that they don't realize they
see like the amount of podcasts there
are yeah but don't wanna thinks like all
raw like give it three months half yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah half of them ain't
gonna be here like there's opportunity
in everything you do like that's the
reason why we promote our stuff heavily
in terms of like so first so for example
so everyone knows on Twitter that guy
that goes is Friday there there's a
nerds in the god has danced in unlikely
of yellow and whatever the green shorts
or whatever everyone's seen that so he
he was basically did it for fun about a
month and half later he
he was in an advert yay like JIT you
don't understand how how easy it is for
you to do something you just love for
fun and it can turn into a business
bang because it's just the fear of two
evils probably shook doing the first one
thinking I look like an idiot [ __ ]
idiot boy it's probably these boys that
back to do funny funny there he's now in
it adverts like and he's gonna get paid
for that he's gonna get paid for doing
stuff he does for fun bro and that's
that is the winning ticket of life
actually stuff get paid for stuff you do
for fun is is the golden life that's it
you unlock like right you've you've one
life you've one life because that's true
happiness happiness you're a common you
you all got money in your bank and you
just image it you love just doing [ __ ]
you love a daily basis and it that love
when I say true love true love like you
do it for free
yeah this like I would we are doing me
doing it you gotta do it for free we do
it for a deficit been doing it I'm in
the hole we're doing this for a deficit
oh we're in the hole but we love it so
we keep doing it it's been months now we
keep going we're still going umm so when
we get paid it's like Gang Gang even if
I look up the patron and we're making
one pound a month thank you get paid
thank you that's paid at paying us 1
pound a month bro game paid 12 pound a
year you believe in a [ __ ] you mad [ __ ]
you umm so yeah man it's live I love
road win in life that's why I like I
also get annoyed because of how
passionate I am for that in front of it
I'm like I it it bothers me a little bit
when like people I love what I do
yeah I love what I do yeah I love what I
do like I love this on that back it's
simple would you do for free if you
answers no you don't love it yeah 100%
and that's fine just you don't have to
pretend like you love it it's fine it
wouldn't like people get offended when
you're like if I said to someone why
would you do it for free and now of
course I'm not gonna do it for free and
then if my retort was okay then you
don't love it they think I'm in
confrontational yeah yeah yeah like what
I do but he's a job
I never have a bad day what constant
I've never had I think because I always
love [ __ ] vomit I didn't want to [ __ ]
ass that day I [ __ ] vomit you might
need to see it patreon
that reminds me that one's on paper
that's a special request a special a
special request episode couldn't handle
my booze and he threw the [ __ ] through
the [ __ ] up that's gonna be on the
patreon if you want to see that if you
want to see yeah if you want to see me
looking absolute mess sign up to the
patreon but boy yeah it's doing doing
what you love for a living
he's just it's the winning ticket how is
that real life you look at anything how
is that real a lot of people do that now
man like I think people make more money
in social media now then they have
social music social medias premier about
10 years old its new 15 years old its
new my people only started making money
from it probably in the last five years
oh yeah 100% and it's it's it's crazy
because it's not it's not one person
that's making money on social media
there's millions of people out there
making money it's a ridiculous amount of
people that making money and people say
it's a saturated market but people make
money off it every single day yeah off
Instagram or Twitter or Facebook of
snapchat off bro everything that's the
way I look at it like when especially
with like obviously I look at that like
the drop-off point in the life line
semester stats yeah but like stats aside
like you already know like I'm a dreamer
I'm a dreamer
nothing like like I said to you on the
podcast the other a few episodes ago
yeah when I was like being the star of
your own movie and stuff yeah yeah yeah
regardless this is always gonna be my
own movie yeah I'll never get to change
that yeah so with the highs and the lows
I'm always gonna be the star of this
movie yeah
so when people like eat you up with like
this it's a traumatic here or what are
the odds and so far then I think like
right is someone going to start a
podcast from today
yeah if someone is do you think there is
ever gonna be a person from today that
starts a podcast from now and ends up
being extremely successful from it the
answer is definitely yes there will be
someone who does it yeah so why not me
yeah so why can't that be me yeah like
if there's one person that does it why
can't that be me and there's the thing
when the lorry obviously when the lorry
stupid odds stupid odds and I don't even
play the lottery because of how
outrageously unlikely it is yeah but
someone's got almost gonna win it yes
they always [ __ ] with ya there's
always a [ __ ] winner over there so
why not so why don't I meet me yeah Bo
so yeah I love stuff like that I love
dreamin about [ __ ] and yes maybe I'll
only be successful we'll maybe we'll
only blow up one we're like 75 years old
but I'll still want [ __ ] I'll still
want an Aston Martin when I play I still
wonder nothing about what I said you why
I'm still alive when I'm saying alright
so why not bro exact beacon of not asked
am i speaking of law reward you do feel
on the lorry oh my what would you do
what's the first thing you do right I've
thought I've had this conversation so
many times with so many different people
I would be the most boring but most
happy lottery whenever so anyhow this is
exactly why do boring in terms of like I
just wouldn't do anything lavish mmm-hmm
really maybe like one holiday or
something like a one trip with you man
or something like that that's just like
this is an experience I would never
thought maybe one of those that's just
pure fun yeah but apart from that
literally it would just be by my side my
mom rents our house mm-hmm
by that because she [ __ ] stresses
about it yeah even though it doesn't
matter yeah and by that to make her
happy she doesn't really care about
anything else material she's already
told me she doesn't ever want to stop
working so I wouldn't do anything else
I'll just buy the house yeah so she
doesn't pay rent imagine have to pay
mortgage always said I'll buy my dad
mastermind yeah and that's me however I
spoken about the the debt on their hear
that dad and ask them I'm f---ing know
why I realized I could never have a
conventional job no right so I've ever
told you the story I don't think so I
don't know you may have caught me a lot
stories so let me digress and then I
promise you we'll get back to the lorry
thing yeah mana because I like the
lottery stories yeah this is a bit deep
with the dad and asked him I think so my
dad I think I've said before my dad was
well-off he's well off and he had he's
always had like high-paying jobs and
suffer that and he was working as a
directing these fly as flies in here
Pham nearly lost it bro nearly lost my
dad's always been well-off yeah yeah as
long as I can remember anyway obviously
wasn't always been one off but yeah he's
had a successful career yeah yeah and he
loves cars and all that stuff and as
long as I can remember Aston Martin he's
been like one of my dad's favorite like
if he ever sees an Aston Martin he's
gasps yeah and he's had cars and cars
and Cosby he's never got one and for the
life of me I'm never asked him why he's
never got one yeah but he's just never
got one so as a kid I've always said I'm
gonna get one him are you said to
yourself I've said to him I'm gonna buy
him one and I've said to myself I'm
gonna buy him one yeah
even before I buy myself when I'm buying
dad and Astor mine yeah and as a kid
every kid thinks they're gonna be rich
when they grow up
yeah of course yeah every kid of course
and I just thought I'm gonna get that
mastermind and he's gonna be buzzing
because my dad you can't get my daddy
excited about [ __ ] yeah you can't get my
dad excited about [ __ ] yeah he don't
give a [ __ ] like is that one of those
things out what do you man what do you
get the man who has everything
yeah like it's one of those things and
as the mind is the one thing he's never
got himself yeah and I've always wanted
to get it for him and I said to him
obviously I'm gonna give you it cetera
cetera cetera cetera yeah and he's like
yeah yeah and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about stuff like that like he no suffer
that he killed us give a [ __ ] about look
like he's so how do I say so hard to
impress like I remember one day my
brother got a pay rise at his job I was
like dad I've got pay rise and he was
like the youngest my like youngest
senior manager in his company and all
the stuff that my brothers crushed it
yeah he went to my dad's one time is our
dad yeah I got his promotion I'm gonna
dis much money now yeah it was a healthy
amount of money yeah yeah I'll make it
this much money and my dad turn around
was I oh really that's that's good man
and he was at yeah I'm making this much
when he's not rah so yeah this much
money I think it was like some of that
40 grand yeah and he was like my brother
was like 20 at the time he must be like
23 yeah so he's coming in that 40 grand
at 23 that's a big money for that age a
big amount my car
like bang bang by Omega 40 and that's a
40 I think I paid that in tax last year
bro shut down the entire thing in me I
was bursting out laughing myself pissing
myself my dad didn't give up [ __ ]
like you can't impress my dad you can't
he refuses he refuses to be impressed I
think I paid that tax last year if I was
your brother at that moment of a cried I
cried how dare you burst my bubble
either
bro my dad I give a [ __ ] oh my day these
are now so he's just a dick he's like
the nicest guy ever but that's funny so
yeah I got paid in taxes last year bro
Wow [ __ ] so yeah that's my dad like
in a nutshell so I've always said ass
tomorrow gonna get that disaster mine
and a few years ago this is when I was
working at David Lloyd my brother me and
brother were carpooling because when we
when we lived together so he used to
drive he worked he worked at very close
to where I died
so for work and stuff like that yeah or
I drop him and we was driving to work
one day and we passed an Aston Martin
garage yeah dealership and I was I
[ __ ] asked him answer
I can't wait to buy this is only like
two years ago I can't wait to write out
that ask them I in and then for some
reason it hit me and I was like how am I
gonna buy dad that yeah let's talk
semantics how am I actually buying this
under wine and I was thinking about it
and I was like the way my life is going
yeah that's never gonna happen yeah
that's never ever I'm in my twenties and
granny that's early bottom like what
career path can I possibly because of
working in sales at a time and I was
like even if I get to like the upper
echelon of sales yeah which I probably
won't yeah cuz I just don't give a give
a [ __ ] yeah just might say you know it's
like even if I do yeah I'm not gonna
have enough money so that I can buy
someone else another my like that's
that's 100 grand car yeah like I am not
gonna have enough money to buy someone
else Anasta mine yeah I'm never gonna
have that kind of money
yeah I broke that it literally hit me in
my chest and I could have cried yeah I
could have cried my eyes out and I'm
just
thinking like it's never gonna happen
yeah how am I gonna do it my one dream
of my life is never ever gonna happen
yeah and I was like wow no no no no no
this car is copy it can't be real yeah
yeah I must be able to buy this [ __ ]
ass tomorrow yeah I just must be yeah
like isn't isn't it's non-negotiable I'm
buying the estimate yeah and that's when
I realized like something like social
media or something like a podcast or
something it's something that I'm
passionate about and something that has
the opportunity to dictate I can be in
control of how much money I want to make
yeah I can be in control like it's not a
case of I have to come in and do eight
hours a day 40 hours a week yeah like
something where I'm working for myself
so I can be in control of my income yeah
that's what I need to do and I can have
multiple sources of income
I was thinking that's the only [ __ ]
way I'm gonna buy dad this as the mine
and less up in the lorry and that's the
day I was just like I need I need to do
something I need to do something I need
to do something and obviously yeah the
start the [ __ ] I didn't come to my head
straight away I was obsessed with Paco
so happy for years but yes that starting
my own wasn't wasn't at the top of
wasn't before frontier yeah it wasn't
the forefront until I spoke to a couple
friends and they were like oh well I
think I was talking to I was talking to
one of my friends Josh who listens to a
lot of the podcasts and he said to me
randomly like bro you would be good on a
podcast and I was like really
I don't think so they don't think so and
he was like now I think you'd be alright
you should do one was this prior to your
previous YouTube channel this was prior
to the previous YouTube channel so this
is prior to my previous YouTube channel
and I was like I don't know man I don't
know I don't know he was at now trust me
I think you'd be really good man and I
was like oh thanks bro we kind of left
it there and then I pursued the YouTube
channel really enjoyed it for a while
and then realized that's not what I want
to do yeah this is something I can
sustain long time yeah it's just not
enjoyable enough for me and then the
whole time I was just like a lot to do
cause I'd love to do Pacus but it's just
like it's something that I just can't
grasp it's like me saying now like I'd
love to be a brain surgeon yeah like
it's just I don't even know how it get
yeah yeah yeah yeah some reason some
hookers it just seemed impossible
Oscar's yeah he looks at us and I have
no idea why he just did mmm
and then I figured out research learned
from doing the previous YouTube channel
I learned about microphones are not
about audio I learned about
synchronization I learned about editing
video I learned about editing audio
alert about all these things and all
these different platforms of stuff and
then it kind of pieced itself together
to a point where I was like oh I'm
pretty sure if I wanted to start podcast
yeah all I all I'd need to do is x y&z
yeah I'm pretty sure if I just do X Y
and Zed I can start it Marin in mind
a normal person would think why didn't
you just Google how odd class do that's
just not how I'm on my way
yeah yeah yeah things that's how it
works yeah but in a grand scheme plan
yeah like a life-changing thing
my mind doesn't work like just google it
like that's not in my my brain coin I
have to understand it you can't just
read Y just get this get this yeah yeah
yeah I need to understand how everything
pieces together yeah I'm going to invest
my life and my time indeed nothing I
can't just google it I know you mean so
once I've truly understood it off my own
back yeah almost like rah I think I just
need to do X Y Zed and I'm pretty sure I
know how to do that now I know how to do
that now and not to do that now so if I
just get this this and this I think I
can do it and then I did start googling
how to do it and it was exactly what I'm
doing here and I was like [ __ ] I can do
it yeah and then the whole time was this
is that I knew this was the type of
podcast I wanted to have mmm I knew I
didn't want to do by myself
mm-hm and you sadly I didn't want to do
about myself is that because of your old
necessarily just because my old you
defect yes and no it was a little bit
because of my old channel yes obviously
by myself yeah and that was difficult
yeah because there's no one to bounce
off but it was also a case of just if
it's funny if it's something that I want
to be funny yeah I want to laugh yeah
myself yeah I don't want to sit there
and say [ __ ] I think is funny oh you're
not in the way other people through this
glass pane yeah
I love the other side when I'm not even
laughing myself
I'm just saying [ __ ] yeah so I wanted it
to be something like that so you need
someone to bounce on yeah and you like I
like conversations yeah and
conversations can go and go and go and
go as they have been yeah and I just you
were the first person that gets my head
and then you pied me off when you buy me
off when the first ever time were boy to
your attention you said I come with what
your thing was but I said it and you
were like yeah you didn't take it
seriously I said it and I was I mean you
like we were just having one of our
normal text back and forth and I was
laughing laughing yeah and I said
something like bro this would be so good
luck on a podcast or something mm-hmm
and then you were like you your response
was like on camera question mark like
something like me on camera question my
now that was your response and then I
just shut it down there I was like okay
and then I think I bought up another
time yeah and you didn't really invest
as if I was being serious
so I remember saying something like brah
want to start podcast with you or
something like that and then you didn't
really bite to a point where I thought
I'm not gonna push this guy into it yeah
so I asked my brother and he said no I'm
alright so yeah I was just kind of just
stuck with it didn't want to do if
anyone else it was either you or him had
no interests are doing of anyone else no
interest whatsoever and then I thought I
could do it just go around to different
people every time and do that either
yeah cuz there's only a few people that
I'm even interested in his organ - yeah
um so it's just like [ __ ] what I'm gonna
do what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do and
then yeah eventually you came around I
kept I kept bringing it up and then yeah
there was one time you were like I can't
member Howie I don't remember at all how
it came to be
neither do I that's weird actually never
do a thing I don't remember buying you
off the first time that's exact I
remember exact that one thing would do
me on camera now most but I don't I
don't actually remember the day it was
agreed that we're actually gonna do it
which is weird to me that I can't remem
that because it would have been a
life-changing plant it would have been a
big deal way and I for some reason I
can't remember but yeah anyway here we
are I took a couple months for me to get
the [ __ ] mmm and then we got it and now
here we are yeah mom it's good I'm happy
mm-hmm because this is part of my life
routine no 100 sent hundred I couldn't I
couldn't see any other way to be honest
bro same [ __ ] lottery man go back to
it
sorry [ __ ] you no lottery see yeah but
my mom my mom's house yeah okay that the
Aston Martin yeah and then I would
literally tell my brother to quit his
job yeah he'll be my business manager
and he can just invest he knows
everything
Doris knows everything yeah so just
invest my [ __ ] yeah make me more money
yeah buy a comfortable house yeah just a
sit just chill just a nice car nice
house and I'll be kidding I'll just do
this yeah we do this I'll get us a fly
studio yeah and now I'll just do this
all time so I don't make you quit your
job as well obviously you'll be creating
a job as well and then we just do this
all the time obviously what I would do I
think I'll do like they're not the
standard norm that everyone would do
I'll obviously retire my parents or yeah
sure I'll give my sister money because
this is Mary she's got a nephew just got
a nephew I've got a nephew she's got a
kid brother
I'll I'll make sure they're like because
what lottery is what double figures in
terms of like it's like 20 something
minimal days it's not triple is it not
true euros triple I think yeah lottery
can be single to double single to double
see rarely but sometimes euros is triple
yeah I say let's save it argue mistake
fifty mil retire my parents give them
probably I'll probably give my mum and
dad like 10 mil not each like five
village
because I feel that's enough that's
enough like day broke never made five
mill in their life's exactly a 5 mils
enough each is enough I'll probably it
my sister a mill to start with let her
do what everything she wants see but I
would never not say no to them if they
want my anything I'll give I'll give all
my clothes poison no like ever
thinking one of my like my close close
friends don't give them all a million
pounds I'll probably outside almost quit
as well and yeah I'll fly us holiday
float like all of us are going out like
we're going abroad abroad bro and abroad
we're gonna do a tour of the world
because everyone's creating a job 100
everyone's quitting a job well my boys
I'm giving money to I'll quit the job
101 doing a tour of the world
Anabella as well she's quitting a job
doing a tour and we're just gonna go
hard for at least a couple months yeah
yeah and now we're gonna come back
recoup get a nice spot like I said like
you said rawa we'll get a studio for
this and we're just bang this out for
the rest of my life some um let's just
be chill be we can even take this abroad
when we go abroad for begin like what we
will do actually a hundred percent is we
would visit the top three countries now
[ __ ] without that [ __ ] with us like
every every quarter or so that sounds
dope and then we can do it in their
backyard kind of thing yeah and then
they can probably see us do it live yeah
you know I mean [ __ ] like that here
that'll make this big win the lorry from
yours better my winner boy with the
[ __ ] Laurie I don't play the lottery
that's why my clucking gambling upstroke
[ __ ] it out